we live in conspiratorial times deeply
sinister motives appear to be at work
everywhere beneath the surface no one
however high their reputation is
entirely beyond suspicion every
institution even the most venerable may
be at it whatever may publicly be said
something a whole lot Garcia is probably
going on in private taking anything on
good faith seems a sure route to naivety
and dissolution it's never been a more
tempting moment to become a conspiracy
theorist but the real choice isn't
between naivety on the one hand and
conspiracy theory on the other a task is
to find our way to an often elusive
third option intelligent skepticism both
the intelligent skeptic and the
conspiracy theorist start from the very
same place with an awareness that things
may well not be what they seem
and that what's widely believed may be
patently false this is in itself no sign
of madness or delusion it's the basis of
some of humanity's greatest discoveries
and insights to claim that the Earth
orbits the Sun would have sounded the
height of delusion in 1473 it would have
sounded no less peculiar to maintain in
the late 1950s that the UK security
services were largely in the hands of a
group of people working for the Soviet
Union a hypothesis can be thoroughly
outlandish very unpopular and still
correct what separates the conspiracy
theorists from the intelligent skeptic
is not the possession of some odd
sounding hypotheses it's what they then
go on to do with these hypotheses
here are some of the key differences
intelligence skeptics know that
hypotheses cannot be sustained
indefinitely without evidence they can
be trialed for a time but eventually
have to be positively backed up by
concrete proof or else graciously and
uncomplainingly abandoned intelligent
sceptics know that the burden of proving
a hypothesis must invariably fall on
them as the challenges to the status quo
and not on the upholders of the
established ideology they accept that
it's their duty to show that ghosts
really do exist and not the
responsibility of everyone else to prove
that they don't up holding quarrelsome
hypotheses delivers some hugely
redemptive emotional pleasures one often
feels empowered and superior to all
those who still blindly trust in the
status quo they the idiots may well
think the rocket went to the moon but we
know the whole thing was filmed in a
downtown studio our job may not be so
significant nor our house very grand but
we unlike the stuck-up professors know
what really happened to the Fuhrer after
the war intelligent sceptics certainly
know how nice it would be if they were
proved right but they can bear the
humiliation of turning out to be
miserably wrong it would of course be
deeply emotionally convenient if they
really were to discover the secrets of
cheap nuclear fishing
if the elderly rich man was in truth a
sexual predator or if climate change did
turn out to be a hoax but they're also
wise enough never to let their wishes
overpower the more stubborn and
unyielding claims of reality the
conspiracy theorist sees skullduggery
everywhere their default position is
that everyone must be a liar and simply
everything is a cover-up their fear of
being taken for a dupe is so great
there could be no glimmer of trust for
their part the intelligent skeptic
proceeds through the world with an
attitude of basic credence and initial
benevolence they dare to take things at
face value confident in their power to
alter their
perhaps quite quickly in a much darker
direction were the facts to demand it
they are internally strong enough to
take a chance to believe in a goodness
and truthfulness of strangers conspiracy
theory is never really a problem of
intelligence
it's an emotional wound that overpowers
the higher faculties of the mind and is
therefore best treated not with a
barrage of countervailing facts but with
reassurance kindness and love for it's
here that the problem invariably began
the choice we face isn't between naive
credulity and conspiracy theory by
understanding the fragility of our
psyches we have the option of navigating
our perilous times with a judicious
mixture of doubt and Trust
you